as some of you know we've been doing
cryptocurrency content on our YouTube
channel for a couple of months including
some under written videos which have
really helped to supplement our ad
revenue without disrupting the broadcast
show and people here can probably mostly
guess what my position is on crypto
which basically is I think there is a
place long term for cryptocurrency I
believe it is highly speculative I
believe there are lots of projects that
are taking advantage of the ICO craze to
try to just pull money from people who
aren't doing research and I think that
putting any more than for most people
six to eight percent or at the very most
nine percent ten percent of one smut of
one's money in crypto is very very risky
that's not financial advice it's just my
opinion
that being said to restate I think there
are some really valuable aspects to
cryptocurrency
and we are seeing potentially very
significant mainstream adoption of
crypto there are more and more
businesses accepting crypto as payment
but more interestingly to me there are
some legacy venture capital firms
starting to invest in crypto and
recently the CEO of Nasdaq said that
they're open to becoming a
cryptocurrency Exchange and the Nasdaq
is sort of the tech version of the New
York Stock Exchange to explain it in the
simplest possible terms it's the second
biggest exchange by volume to the NYSC
and it disproportionately lists tech
companies and their CEO Adina Friedman
recently said that she certainly would
consider making Nasdaq a crypto exchange
over time and this was simultaneously
hugely exciting and hugely scary to
people in the crypto space it was
exciting because right now crypto
exchanges are to put it lightly not the
most prestigious institution certainly
not compared to the Nasdaq and Nasdaq
crypto exchange where you can trade
between cryptos and most importantly
between US dollars and cryptos would
lend a level of legitimacy to crypto
currency that would be monumental merely
the involvement of NASDAQ and
Krypto will hugely increase adoption in
the space but this is also freaking out
some crypto communities because of
regulation fears the idea that listen if
Nasdaq gets involved the entire
financial regulation space will
immediately be very interested in
controlling the space and regulating it
and with crypto being so libertarian
oriented and sort of anti regulation
minded they don't necessarily like it
there's the other possibility that if
Nasdaq gets involved in a crypto
exchange it opens the door to market
manipulation and massive margin trading
and a lot of other risky activity which
also may not be good for the crypto
industry and certainly not good for the
economy
and then lastly one of the main appeals
of the crypto currency space is
decentralization as one of its benefits
so these centralized exchanges are at
odds with one of the underlying tenets
of cryptocurrency to have a massive
legacy corporate financial world
exchange for cryptocurrency that will be
centralized at a systemic level kind of
goes against what many of these
technologies were developed to be so I
don't want to delve too much more into
this now since only some people in our
audience follow the crypto space but we
will definitely be talking about it more
on our YouTube channel over time today's
episode of the program is made possible
in part by coin schedule which is a
listing site for cryptocurrency icos
that's been around since 2016 and was
actually one of the first websites to
show helpful listing information about
icos where you can look them up by name
by industry by start and end date and
you'll get from coin schedule a score
for each IC o----
that can help you better assess how
careful you should be if you are looking
at investing in any particular IC o----
coins schedule like me says that they
hate scams and one of the guys from coin
schedule was actually telling me about
how they do everything they can to weed
out the scam IC o---- so that they
straight-up don't appear on their
website and it seems that they've
learned a lot from doing this over the
past two years coin schedule is also
a really good resource for finding
information about upcoming
cryptocurrency related conferences they
also post crypto news and if you're
watching this on YouTube I put a link to
the coin schedule website at the top of
the description to be clear nothing on
coin schedule should be considered
personalized investment advice icos are
risky everybody should do their own
research and make the decisions that are
right for them